I'm gonna have to find an alternative to
reream. This thing just is not doing it.
It just has no resilience to anything.
All right. Well, the YouTube one's back
up. That's so obnoxious, though.
Hey Finn, the YouTube stream just got
cut off, man. I don't know what
happened. The Twitch one didn't go down.
We're just all sorts of weird stability
things with reream today.
Did you try this without layer?
Obviously, you need the residual
parameters. Let me see.
Uh, hang on. Is that going to let me?
Without layerorm does worse. Do you have
the ops normalized?
I really try to avoid layerorm when I
can. Swish a little worse than Aello.
Can you post the uh Are you in the
Discord, Kevin? Can you drop the link
there? My chat is like totally messed
up. Reream like the whole UI is
basically not working on my dashboard
today. I can't even click links.
I'd like to look through the results.
Okay.
So we have
Okay. Okay. So we have depth
interesting in depth. Nice.
I guess it's the uh ranges.
Oh, and I see the params. Okay. So,
model params.
The six
Wait, that's not 40 mil, right? That's
That's like five mil, isn't it?
Like the uh the top results here. This
is like 5 mil
or Well, I can't read this axis. I don't
know what this is. Wait, one, two, is it
less than 5 mil?
Wait, one, two, three, four. Yeah, five
mil.
Why is Lenor bad? Because it's like it's
slow.
depth 64 is is 40 mil. Yeah, this this
one over here it's right
reward base rather goal main thing is
how to figure out yeah so that would be
the main thing and that's why I didn't
really look at the paper very much
because we need that in order for it to
be useful
like pure goal condition just doesn't
even make sense, right? If you think
about it because pure pure goal
condition,
so Kevin, like pure goal conditioning
is
that's basically like having a one
reward at the end of your task, right?
Like a like a fully sparse reward.
We do goal conditioned RL like we do
task conditioned RL rather I should say
but we do it via the reward function and
via the difference in observations and
actions right so like for instance the
drones can have different formations
that they have to fly into all right but
that's like they're observing different
target states right and they're getting
rewarded for different things
and we can make I guarantee you We can
make fully sparse reward work for things
that where you would not think that they
work. Did you see the maze result in my
uh my post here? Let me show you
something. And I think you'll appreciate
this since you actually have the
background to know what this uh to know
what you're looking at here.
Where's this thing?
Oops.
See, most most people will not have the
background to appreciate this, which is
why I don't show this super often.
except to other researchers.
But um
sitting here. Yeah. Look at this maze.
The reward for that is it's a full
sparse reward. Yes, that is trained on
fully sparse reward. It is insane.
Puffer li is actually that good.
So you can see Kevin like
we kind of do some good research around
here, right?
It's in the puffing up PO article.
Trajectory segment filtering gives you
uh implicit curriculum learning which
for stuff like this is really good.
That plus being able to train this,
we're able to train like a 2 million
parameter network on this thing at 2
million steps per second almost.
Send in the link. This is just in my
articles tab. Major.
Yeah, I can put this in the Discord.
It's literally just my like if you just
read the articles that I have, right?
Like you'll see we do our own research.
All right. Like
I don't really publish a ton of stuff
anymore because I'm no longer in
academia, but I am very much still ad
like the goal is to advance the field
here,
right? We do our own stuff.
Isn't maze what goal condition RL is
really good at? Wouldn't work on this
one.
What are your thoughts on aquaction
sequence modeling?
just supervised learning.
You need to have the action sequences to
train on.
Oh, Finn, the max rings plus one was for
the observations. They are they include
the current and the next rings.
Yeah, I get I got you, Finn. I changed
it. I'm thinking of changing it back,
but that's not the thing breaking it.
Maze results is very impressive. Never
seen that performance before. Yeah,
this is reward based. It's literally it
just gets one for getting the goal. It
doesn't like get the it's not like a
goal state thing. It's just one for the
reward.
So you you kind of see like you have to
be doing RL to understand how good that
result is. But uh this is kind of why I
say that we've made the first like the
first major algo breakthrough in RL
since PO cuz like that just works and
that trains in minutes.
The hyper prams are very specific for
it. Like you actually have to do a quite
aggressive hyperparameter sweep in order
to get the ones that solve it that fast.
But it does replicate like it like it
does that every time.
How much data does it require?
Probably 15 minutes times 1 to 2 million
steps per second would be my guess.
We go by wall clock. So, uh, yeah, it's
going to be a lot of data. What would
that even be?
Let's say a minute.
It's somewhere between one and three
billion steps probably.
It's not just a th00andx speed. That
helps, but it's not just a thousand x
speed. And you can see right here, look,
see this curve? It's trained in less
than 12 minutes. The best models.
So,
Are you interested in like if you can
figure out how to make that thing not
have to be goal conditioned, right? If
it can take in reward like I'm fine
having an auxiliary supervised loss if
it's like next state prediction or in
like or ideally like latent space
prediction or something. Um,
but we would like to have something that
lets us scale up models like that.
My thousand layer that takes like a few
days. Yeah, exactly.
So, I mean, if you're interested in
trying to like get some of your stuff
working in Puffer, right, we'd be very
very happy to have work on scaling up
networks around in here.
would actually unlock quite a few
applications.
So the main thing I would be wanting to
do next on the research side anyways.
So here's the crazier result, Kevin.
This one is here's the real scale up
result that we have.
If you just um if you watch this guy
play for a few minutes, you'll kind of
get the idea.
Okay,
that's tool use right there. Just it
just figured out how to equip and use
tools.
All right, it just equipped it a full
armor set.
If you watch this thing, you'll see it's
like a not a half bad MMO agent. And we
trained this thing ourselves on one
server.
This thing was trained on more than a
pabyte of observations. It's the other
article on my X.
640 billion steps.
Took like three days on a tiny box.
I'm pretty sure the only things that are
larger than this are like Dota and
Alphaar and like Go pretty much just the
big lab results are bigger than this
and they all use like you know a
thousand plus GPUs.
Here's the cool thing. This thing
actually the highle opponents have
ranged attacks and it knows that they
have ranged attacks and it knows how to
kite melee and ranged. Look, it's
literally kiting with a bow.
I can't even do that consistently
without like screwing up and getting
hit.
It's like frame perfect kiting. Um, it
took one hit.
Hey Simon, have you thought of doing
some kind of RL for robotics?
Some things like pit control theory.
Yeah, so we started doing some stuff on
Manny scale. I wouldn't do Pi Bullet or
Majoko or like or Ross. They're all
super super slow. I did start working on
some stuff with manny skill. I want to
continue it. It's just it's time and
like other stuff I have to be doing at
the moment. Um highfidelity control is
considerably more work than low fidelity
control. For like the time being when I
get a chance to finish the manuscale
integration, you can basically expect
like a hyperparameter tuned version of
that that runs on puffer lib. Uh, but in
order to make it like way better, I'd
have to get very very deep into physics
sim for robotics. And like it's an
amount of work that we would basically
we would only do that amount of work if
somebody wanted to sign a big contract
with us to do it because otherwise it's
like I can't just be like detouring and
spending months on that, right?
That's nice. Thanks for the trims. Yeah,
you got it.
So yeah, Kevin, there you go. There are
some results.
It's fun to show these to actual
researchers who like understand how hard
some of this stuff is. Time some time to
talk about ants and some updates we can
discuss. Uh, yes, I can do that soon.
was chatting with Kevin here and I do
want to figure what's wrong with my
uh my drone agents first. Let me see if
I can figure that out rather quickly.
Do I have a hypothesis for this or no?
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I knew what I was
going to I was going to do the target
position, right?
does buffer vectorized environments via
async require agents to send actions on
step
actions to some buffer.
Uh that's not what async means in this
context. We could very easily set that
type of thing up, but you would never
want to do that for training. So, we
don't like we don't do that type of
stuff by default. We could set it up for
a specific application quite easily
though.
Okay. So, presumably here,
I'm assuming that this is not actually
correct, right?
I guess we'll have to copy it over to
see.
all this did was update the score to be
the same thing as before. This is not
doing it.
Does it even make sense that you would
have to do this?
It doesn't, right?
I guess it makes sense that they need to
see
collisions and such.
I guess technically let's let's just
copy this real quick.
I'd way rather just be able to deal with
this all locally, but I'm on my laptop,
so
It learns to not OB,
right? But it doesn't learn much else.
What's the vibe? Is this a bunch of
researchers on their own projects?
Everyone's working. So I mean puffer lib
is just a big effort to fix
reinforcement learning in general. So
there's poor research that's shared
across everything. Same with poor
infrastructure. And then uh a lot of the
new contributors we suggest that they
get involved by writing their own
environments. It's really a good way to
get into reinforcement learning. And
then those environments become uh they
become tasks that are used in research.
So like the majority of these are
written by contributors and then when
people get more experienced or people
who are more experienced can also
contribute to core infrastructure and
core research as well.
It really just depends on your
experience, right? We've kind of made it
so that we've gotten it to a point where
even very new people can actually
contribute productively because like
there are a lot of very simple
environments that end up being quite
useful for research. Um and then that
helps you onboard yourself, right? So
that you can actually learn the more
complicated stuff.
Why the heck does the drone do that
is the question, I suppose. Have I just
been lazy and missed something?
I wanted to fix this quickly and catch
up with MTAM.
Um, this thing is driving me nuts
though.
Sick. Thanks. I've been trying to get RL
for designing compliant mechanisms.
Mechanis tons of end steps. I assemble.
Thanks for the content and the
resources. That sounds cool. Um, so if
you have experience in another area, I
don't know if this is a personal project
or a company project. For companies, we
have contracts where we can help. Uh,
for personal projects where you're like
generally interested in building
something applicable to industries
though, uh, that is a good way to get
involved with working with us.
Like we love it when people with
experience in other areas are like
trying to figure out how to make how to
turn a problem that is an industry into
one that can be uh that RL can be
applied to. We've helped with that in a
number of different areas.
If only I could figure out why the drone
does not work.
Oh yeah, I was going to do uh the ring
reward, right? Ring
check ring.
Wait, reward or
based on distance to the ring center.
I mean, this reward doesn't look good to
me, but the thing is,
The score is higher.
I need to add like a rings
ring solved thing.
That's meaningfully different at the
very least, right?
I wonder why that didn't mess it up
before.
I mean, I guess it's just the the
permutation.
Yeah, that's like huge difference.
See, this is like the type of thing that
you're just not going to find or
understand until you've done more RL
generally.
Of course, this is going to cause like
there going to be some slight problems
with this. Like you can see it's dipping
and going back through the same ring,
which is a kind of a funny approach
that we don't want it to do, but like
this fixes it. So, it's basically just a
reward/curriculum bug. And that looks
super smooth.
I mean, literally like look how smooth
this thing is, right? Look at this.
what else do we get to do?
Let's do this in it.
So, we're going to now randomize the
drone.
If this works, then this will mean that
um
we can fly we can fly the course with
like any randomized drone that we want.
And then uh
well, I mean this sets us up in a pretty
good spot.
M10, you still around?
Um, I don't know. It's your username's
M10. Matan,
are you still around?
I can take a look at the ant stuff now.
I wanted to uh at least get something
training though for this.
Oh, yeah. Look, it's the same. Perfect.
I will hop in the uh the Discord
on this provided you're comfortable
doing it on stream.
And for new folks around here, this is
literally how it works. When you get in
uh into a new project and start debing,
it's just like
come join. I will come look at your code
and such.
Hey,
uh yes, but let me route that through
the correct device real quick that is
going through my speakers.
ah
this needs to be plugged in for it to
work, doesn't it?
Yes. Let me just fix it for the stream
as well.
We will be we will be good.
Huh.
I don't know why the
I'll fix the desktop audio. Get the
thing working and I'll figure out how to
I'll fix stream is stream is down on
YouTube. I think it says it's up. Did it
crash?
It's been crashy all day.
No, it still has me as live. Did it
crash?
Still has me as live.
I just started with ML. Getting
confused.
Courses. Every time I get to some new
topic, feels like I don't know it. Stuck
on one piece.
and build without tutorials.
Follow my guide, my guide that is on X
submit. I it's I put like all my best
advice and stuff for new programmers,
new to ML, new to RL. That's all in the
guide.
Let me figure out why this audio is
being weird.
>> Okay, now it works, I think.
>> Wait.
>> Cool.
>> Yeah. Yeah, now it works. Cool.
>> Can you see the ants?
Um, let me get the stream open.
Oops. And now we have ants.
>> Cool. So, yeah, you can see here the
ants are moving around randomly at the
moment. Uh, this is like my dot/ ants
command. This isn't uh the eval.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, but I've I've added a feature where
when I hit shift I' I can now observe
the observations for
>> Yeah, that's generally a good idea to
do. And yeah, um and so that's given me
a lot more observ observability into how
effectively my helper functions are
working and um how good the results are.
So as far as position X and Y, that all
seems to be accurate. It seems to be
correctly ranged between zero and one.
Um and that seems to be no problem. uh
direction is either one of 0.25.5
75 or zero right for the four directions
that the ant can be moving in.
>> Um has food is a boolean.
>> Uh that's right. So the way they're
doing that is they're just moving down
and then left and then down and then
left and then down and left and down and
left. Um
>> yeah. Uh, but the four directions that
they can be moving in in a given frame
is going to be up, down, left, or right.
>> Do they train?
>> Um,
>> yeah. So, this does run if I do a puffer
train.
>> Um, the results are just not where I'd
like them to be.
>> Does it do anything like anything that's
clearly learning or not really?
>> Uh, not really. Yeah, I would say um
it's not really learning uh the way
it should be. Like
>> how many kicks does it take?
>> I don't see any progression left right
uh to reach food for the first time. You
mean
>> like
>> not remember we had this conversation of
like the granularity of movement?
>> Yeah. So
>> I'll refresh a so like If it takes a
very very long time, like if it takes a
100 actions to randomly find food,
>> like in the best case,
>> that's tough.
>> Yeah. So, I've also run this with the
ants being able to move much faster
>> um with similar results. Uh so, I've
I've had it where they're moving like 10
times faster than they are right now.
Um, and it's similarly
uh not learning when I look at the uh
runs, right? Um,
>> have you had anyone look at the code for
like basic sanity?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, um, you might remember
the last Dan.
>> Yeah, I'll send it to you. Dan also
looked at all the like observations,
actions, and rewards code. He should
probably catch stuff. He'll catch the
basic stuff.
>> If there's something more subtle wrong,
he's not going to get it. And I may or
may not get it from like a quick look,
but you can link it to me in Discord and
we'll try.
>> Yeah, sounds good.
Uh, okay.
I want to see the puffer lip fork that I
made. Yep.
Okay. Uh what I have in my local is
slightly different from this just in
terms of the reward function, but
everything else should be the same.
>> Link it.
>> Um
yep.
>> Oh, you're putting in voice.
>> Yeah
thing.
>> All right, we'll take a quick look at
this live here.
strategically named to be alphabetically
first. I see.
>> Um, not done intentionally.
>> No, I'm I'm joking, man. I know. It's
It's funny though.
>> Uh, okay. Let's see.
So, it's done in pixels and this is five
pixels of movement, right?
>> Uh, that's right. Yes. The if the ant
speed is five, then yes. Yeah. Exactly.
You can literally
>> Is there a way for me to see what you're
reading?
>> You've checked the Have you checked the
observations from Python, observations,
rewards, and all that?
>> Yeah. So, I'm I'm confident that all the
numbers are the same if that's what you
mean. Okay. Like the
>> the observation size is always going to
be eight. The number of ants is always
going to be 32.
>> But like the data in there looks
reasonable.
>> It does. Yeah. So I've I've also gone
and like you you saw the observ
observability thing that I had for you
know when it's running
>> like observations from pietorch match
what you're seeing visually
>> I'm not sure I mean they they absolutely
should because I'm not rendering any
like intermediate proxy I'm I'm when I'm
visualizing
>> I'm just checking data corruption is all
I'm doing I'm just checking data
corruption because something like this
should train instantly
>> right so I'm Not sure like I uh I'm not
sure how you would visualize all of the
logs in PyTorch. What I have done is
used the slash utility that I made to
look at the observations of particular
ants
>> to confirm that.
>> Uhhuh.
>> This is this is how you do it. So you
you run eval, you put a break point
>> in uh in like before or after the render
whatever
>> and you look at what you see on the
screen with that with that overlay
running, right? and you can see like the
vectors and where they're pointing and
then you look at the observation data
like you print it out and you see if
those numbers match what you see on the
screen for and make sure like they're
unique for each ant and and all that.
Does that make sense?
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Do that with sanity because like if it's
not learning it's very likely there's
some weird bug.
>> It's also possible that the rewards are
just super screwy. We can see that. But
let's see.
>> Yeah.
>> Spawning ants. I mean, I've tried
different versions of the reward
function. So, I've done a regular reward
function where it just gets a small
reward for picking up food and a bigger
reward for bringing the food back.
>> I've done a anglebased reward function
where they they get those same rewards
from before, but they also get small
rewards for being pointed towards food
if they are not carrying food and being
pointed towards the colony if they are
carrying food. And then food respawns
are like what what do the train curves
look like? Do you have any?
>> Food respawns. I've got 75 that we can
>> Okay. Link me the Neptune.
>> Uh yeah. Let me Is there a way to share
that with your account or copy link to
project? Is that enough?
>> It depends if it's public. Yeah.
>> Is there any reason for it not to be?
>> I don't think so. Uh
>> just link it. All my experiments are
public. It's not a big deal.
I'm sending it to you now. Um, I don't
think I made this private, but let me
know if you have any trouble opening it.
>> Did you DM it to me?
>> Uh, yes.
>> Open.
>> Yeah. And the most recent run, run 75,
is exactly what's in GitHub. Like
there shouldn't be any discrepancy
between those two.
So, this is taking me to my puffer
project.
This is not taking me to your thing.
>> That means it's private.
>> I see when you click the link. Okay.
>> Yeah. So I click this link
>> and it redirects me yeah to my own
project. So I assume that's probably
because it's private. If your project it
should say public right here
>> where is uh right here. Are you sharing
your screen?
>> Uh it's on the stream but if you like
just projects tab on Neptune like
whatever your project is named it should
say public or private.
>> Yep. Yeah. And it's I it says workspace.
Anyone with access to this workspace can
see this project. So I guess I need to
give you access to the work.
>> You have got to invite me or make it
public. One of the two.
>> Okay. One sec.
Um
workspaces.
Workspace settings.
Yep. Uh what would be your username or
email on Neptune?
>> It's probably Juwarispuffer.ai.
I see a Jayce Suarez here.
>> That's fine.
>> All right.
You should have the invite.
>> Let me see if I have to accept it or if
the link will just work now.
>> Seems like you have to accept cuz you're
grayed out.
Okay, we're do we'll do a little quick
experimental.
Did I just close the window by mistake?
All right, here it is.
>> Okay. Uh we'll do a little analysis. So
that's like that's just noise too much.
Anything gets worse
>> Okay. Yeah, we're just looking at
straight noise here.
>> Yeah. For the um the episode return and
everything. Yeah.
Um,
trying to think if I just want to fork
this real quick.
Here, we'll do get this up for you. Why
not?
We'll just do this live. It'll be
quicker anyways.
What was the branch?
>> The branch is feature/puffer ants.
>> Feature/puffer ants.
like the no build isolation and all the
freaking flags are so obnoxious.
I really wish I could make the install
experience for Puffer better, but Python
packaging ecosystem just sucks.
You could probably make aliases for
these things built into puffer lib.
>> Yeah, but the thing is all that that
does that makes it more convenient for
me and it hides the issue that like it's
still whenever anybody does it outside
of our Docker, they have the same
problem.
>> Like you have to have no build isolation
when you install it, otherwise it does
random [ __ ] and gives you
undebugable errors and like there's
nothing I can do about it.
Was it puffer ants?
feature/puffer ants.
>> Uh,
are you able to share your screen
because I can't see the uh screen right
now? I usually
>> let me let me see if uh I I think that
it'll let me let me kill the preview on
my stream first so that I can at least
another three open copies of my own
stream
and switch over so I can read the chat
in the meantime.
Hello to all the YouTube folks. We are
debugging contributor ends live.
If you build some environments, I too
will go over those and help you figure
out all the demons in your RL code.
>> How many ants per environment?
>> Uh, it should be 32 ants per
environment.
>> Okay. So,
wait. 120. No, that's not right. So, 32.
I'm going to just
It's 32, right? Yeah.
So, we're going to do 32 m.
Where do you get these pars from?
>> This was this whole file was given to me
by Dan, but I'm I'm not sure uh what the
whole thought process was.
>> Are you on like a lowend machine or
something?
What's that?
>> What machine are you using to train on?
>> Oh, I'm using uh an M4 Mac.
>> Yeah. So, he probably gave you this
because you can't actually run a proper
training config. Um
would be my guess.
How do you mean like is there some kind
of configuration job or do you mean just
writing that any file
>> like your machine is not going to be
here. I immediately now on my machine I
have this thing training at uh 1.8
million steps per second.
>> Yeah, I mean I can get it to to that
number of steps per second. Um I think
if I were to run a train it would
probably be like a similar steps per
second. Um
>> what's a good Let me see what was your
graphing is not me. Send me some graphs
return.
per score.
>> Okay. So,
>> yeah. So, episode
score is just the amount that they bring
back to the colony. Episode return is uh
the amount of total reward.
Um
>> I think I have your thing training.
>> Yeah. No, this does seem to be working.
See how their score is always zero
though?
That's odd to me
>> because the score seems to be non zero
in the user stats, but whenever I look
at the actual like termination
>> thing being listed out, it always says
score is zero.
>> Okay. I mean, you can run this thing
that I just did locally and take a quick
look at it because I don't have this set
up to render.
>> Um, guess I technically could do that
for you real quick.
It' be a pain to have to set it up on my
local as well.
This is why I hate not having a nice
just not being on a desktop for dev.
>> Yeah. I mean, I'm I'm able to visualize
the eval after the fact.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I I need to do that. Hang.
Maybe I'll just I'll set it up. What
time do I have? I got half an hour. I
can I can get this to work.
>> Let's do it properly. Since we've been
working on this for a while, I'll
actually I'll actually try to do this
correctly.
appreciate it. I'll I'll look at the
score thing that we were just talking
about because I think it is weird that
they're always uh getting printed out at
zero.
>> So, my guess is that Dan gave you that
as a testing config because that's not a
reasonable training config.
>> I see. Yeah. I uh Yeah.
>> And he would and he almost certainly
would know better as well. So,
>> Gotcha. Yeah. Yeah. That could be he was
just uh trying to get
>> probably just trying to get you
something you could play with quickly
that's not like we don't ever train at
that scale that's like horribly horribly
slow and it's not going to be stable.
>> Okay.
>> Like puffer defaults are not set up to
do that in particular.
if I want to learn more about what's
going on in any file or um I guess
knowing what Dan knows um I mean am I
doing the right things just by making an
environment or should I
>> yes
>> read read my guides as well
>> have you read um any of my articles
>> I've I've read most of what you guys
have though on the website yeah
>> okay the two new articles will fill in
all the remaining gaps then. Dan started
less than two years ago with zero
programming knowledge and zero AI
knowledge.
>> Nice. Yeah.
>> So, you will definitely be able to
understand that.
>> Cool.
>> There's of course more gaps what I know,
but you would hope that there would be.
I've been doing this for a while.
>> Mhm.
>> I was going to say I haven't read any of
the update since 3.0. Um,
>> there's we've had a lot of good there's
a lot of good educational material now.
Oh, and I've missed some uh I'm sorry
I've missed some messages apparently.
>> Read your article. It starts with 231N.
What about core MLGO? Where should I
learn it?
I see course skip SVM
the algorithm. Uh, none. You need to
start treating AI as an empirical field
summit. like there isn't good theory
behind most of deep learning. You need
to treat it like an empirical field. All
right? It's like physics. Think of it
like physics, right? Like you can't
prove the equation is correct, right?
You can't prove falsely.
You can show that it fits the data
within certain regimes. Okay? It's like
that.
So, you're not going to really gain any
any intuition about uh ML by studying
SVMs that you won't gain by doing more
modern stuff. It's fine to do some of
the historical stuff and I've done some
of the historical stuff, but especially
when you're starting, it's a really poor
investment of time uh to do that stuff.
Like, you should you should implement
your own basic uh autograd, which you
will do as part of 231N. It's going to
be a lot easier and it's going to teach
you a lot more. Where do you learn X in
your brain? That's the only place you
learn. I don't know what that means.
Okay,
we got the thing copied over. Now I'm
going to go like this.
Get
Where the heck did I put your link? Hang
on.
Um feature/puffer amps.
How's your day going? Otherwise, Joseph,
>> it's all right. I uh was out at a
dentist appointment for the morning, so
I haven't really gotten the chance to do
too much. I've kind of mostly just been
like fixing up the drone end, helping
with a few other things around Puffer
and then building out more of the uh the
company stuff
for a little bit here.
>> Oh, yeah.
Do you guys have any um projects that
companies have come to you with?
>> Yeah, we do. We're working on um you
know, we're working on finding more and
bigger ones. Yeah, we've done a few
things in a few different areas. We have
a couple active
Cool.
Recently, I've been uh thinking about
starting a new project when I get this
one working, which could be um something
more in the biioinformatics.
>> We are definitely interested in that.
>> Yeah,
>> I would uh like a hardcore molecular sim
is ultimately going to be the thing that
I really want to figure out how to do
and how to make it really fast. I think
that like
>> right
>> there's going to be a potential to just
unlock so much stuff if we can do that
but
>> totally
>> you know they're easier problems I can
solve first in lowdimensional control
and logistics that will basically uh I
mean if I do them well I should be able
to permafund the puffer as like a decent
sized private lab that's currently the
objective
>> cool
yeah I have a friend who is a bioinform
formatician who works at Mount Si here
in the city.
>> Oh, cool.
>> Um, yeah, brilliant guy. He's uh one of
the two guys who's conver I I like had a
bunch of conversations with them where
we were just nerding out together
>> and um he's one of the guys who gave me
the idea to work on this ant project. Um
but yeah, he's he's a really brilliant
guy. Um, I'm sure we we could have some
really great conversations about
>> um how to build a model like that. And
he he's less on the CS side of like how
to make it more efficient.
>> Yes, mine.
>> Right.
>> Yeah, I got your end working. I'm pretty
sure.
>> Is this not decent?
>> Yeah. Let me
see.
Wait, they don't look like they're
depositing food all the time when they
go through,
>> right? Uh, well, if they try to deposit
to the wrong colony, then it won't work.
You know what I mean?
>> I see.
>> Um,
>> can they see the color of the colony?
>> They can only see their own colony.
>> I see.
>> In the colony. Uh,
>> so maybe then they're just like
>> I mean it's at least doing something off
the bat when it wasn't doing anything
before.
>> Yeah. I mean um
what did you change actually um before
running this?
>> It would be good. No, I I just saw an
ant by the way. It definitely they can
cross it. I'm pretty sure I saw it frost
where it was the same ant went back and
frost later and it did actually deliver.
>> Huh.
>> Let me see if I can catch it.
>> Oh, it only delivers some of the time,
you're saying. Or
>> I think so. I can't tell.
>> That shouldn't happen. I mean, I
>> maybe not. I could be wrong. I wasn't
looking at the trail colors. I didn't
realize they had trails match the color.
>> Yeah, it'll it'll only accept food from
red ants, the red colony, and will the
blue colony will only accept food from
from blue ants cuz every uh I'm looking
at the
>> H code right now, every time they pass
through it, it's going to check to make
sure that they're at the right colony. I
had an idea for a feature where you
could have it where uh if the ant is not
carrying food and it touches the
opponent colony, then it can steal one
food out of that colony and reduce their
score, right? Um and that could be
interesting because then
>> you have the base,
>> right?
>> Yeah. I mean, um once we get the base
work and I I have a few ideas for how we
could make it more interesting. Like we
could add an adversarial behavior where
they can steal for from each other. We
could add soldier ants so there's like a
conflict or a uh a combat mechanism.
That could be really interesting.
>> Um
and yeah, pherommones still isn't really
fully implemented. Uh their range of
sight is infinite right now. Um,
so there's a few things that I'd want to
upgrade once we get this base working.
>> Why is my
AI?
Okay. So, here is your Yeah. So, I fixed
your thing. Look at this. You see?
>> Yeah. Beautiful.
>> Okay. So, it's it's kind of funny
because I just I deleted the custom
config and I use our defaults.
>> Oh, wow. Okay, cool. That is a beautiful
graph.
>> So, uh,
>> yeah, it you're gonna need to mess with
some like I don't know what your
observations are at the moment. I'm
going to give you a little bit of advice
on that, but um
>> Okay,
>> let me explain to you at least what was
wrong here.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay. And like why the thing that you
had didn't make any sense.
>> Okay.
Okay.
>> You had this num m set to one. Yep.
>> Right.
to 32 amps.
>> Yes,
>> I was getting 82,000 steps. I think by
default we have like two M's in
parallel, so it'll be like 64 total amps
or whatever. Um I was getting 80K steps
per second on my very nice 5090.
So um I mean you could literally the GPU
is so cold you could use it to cool your
drinks at that point. like
>> you from a hardware utilization
perspective it's just not efficient to
run tiny batches and then from a buffer
defaults perspective we don't tune our
defaults uh to make any sense for that
few environments it's not enough
parallel experience
>> uh and the learning rates and stuff it
none nothing matches basically what you
would want for that so our default batch
size is like 500k our default mini batch
is 16 or 32k
Uh and then by default we use like 4096
or 8192 total agents. So by setting
numms ms to 32 32 * 32 is 1024 and then
ve num m is eight. So you're going to
have a total of 8192 agents split across
eight CPU cores. This immediately gets
you up to almost 2 million steps per
second training. I commented literally
everything which is just going to use
our defaults which are tuned on some of
the arcade ends and are generally good
for like most simple tasks that look
kind of like arcade tasks. Um, so that
just instantly worked. And
>> yeah, that's that's pretty much the long
and the short of it. And like you
wouldn't do stuff like this with puffer
because it's just it's so hardware
inefficient that you wouldn't even want
to tune for this if you could get away
with not doing this. I mean for numms
one rather you wouldn't even want to
tune for that because it's always going
to be hardware inefficient because GPUs
with tiny networks and small batch sizes
just don't go together.
>> All right. So now let me let me show you
then the other thing.
So this is like circ uh this is circular
quartz or I first polar quartz.
>> Uh yeah basically um the first eight
observations are for ant uh ID0. The
second set of eight observations is for
ant ID 1 and so on.
And that also goes across the number of
environments. So after the first 32
ants,
>> I think I already then talked to you
about this or you might have just done
it right to begin with. I don't know.
This is fine. What was the rewards?
>> Uh the rewards are going to be
calculated in step. Um
>> yeah,
>> like
>> Yeah.
Exactly.
So if it gets the food,
>> yeah, it gets the reward food.
Otherwise, it gets reward delivery and
that's going to get uh set in the pie.
So I think it's 0.1 and one respectively
right now.
>> Yeah,
>> reward
being used. Um
I thought that just picking up food was
less meaningful than actually returning
it to the colony. So I made the reward
delivery bigger but I have not
experimented with just moving these
numbers to different values that
>> set them both to one by default. And
then what you are going to do is once
you have this thing working sely
look at the neural MMO 3 um
>> inspiration
try to do this. So you see how we have
the n frames in the in
>> yeah got it. Okay, these get passed to
Python and then what you can do is you
can do something like this. You see how
I put into the sweep.
>> Mhm.
>> Now when you run a sweep, you'll
actually sweep the reward coefficients.
So instead of guessing
>> nice. Yeah.
>> You'll just know.
>> That's cool. Yeah.
>> Don't sweep above one though because we
flip to one anyway. So go zero to one or
negative one to one if it's could be
whatever.
>> Yeah, sounds good.
So that's that should be everything that
you need to do in order to get this
environment to work well. Um the
observations are fine. This amp you
might want to crank the amp speed up a
little bit depending. It will make
learning faster at least. Just whatever
makes it look visually good is
>> you know that you can get away with is
probably fine.
>> Yeah,
>> I guess let me think.
Yeah, it's
we try to generally shorten horizons as
much as possible for task, but if it
learns, it learns. Um
>> Okay.
Can you send me the uh any file that you
used for the most recent run?
There you go.
>> Sweet.
Awesome. Yeah. So um just so I
uh am not missing anything you mentioned
um try it with this um one uh run it
with a higher speed include the reward
as parameters in the innie like what
you're doing with neural MMO
>> that's for sweeps
>> um okay
>> so it's the I would say that the exact
order of operation for you is going to
be one, make sure that you can replicate
this and get a baseline graph in
Neptune.
>> Y
>> okay, you can run it a little longer.
You can do whatever you want. Uh play
with knobs to play with. First of all,
see what happens if you just increase
the reward,
right?
>> Okay.
>> If I would hope that score is food
delivered and it's not like the reward,
it's not just correlated reward in any
way. Yeah. Okay. If it's food delivered,
then the graph will be directly
comparable. So you can see if changing
the score makes a difference or not. Um
>> okay then after that you can
you can mess with a little bit. You can
mess with the speed as a knob a little
bit. Heck you can make it a
hyperparameter if you even want to like
the same as you did with the rewards.
And then you can just chuck it all into
a sweep and see what gets the best
score. That'll already get you something
decent.
>> Cool.
>> There you go. Those are my quick
recommendations for you.
>> Great. Replicate the results. Uh change
the reward and make it reward parameters
in the innie. And uh do the same thing
with ant speed.
>> Cool. All right. Awesome. Um I will I
will do that right away.
>> Yeah. Don't forget to put the speed in
the binding file as well that doesn't
get messed up.
Uh, yes. Yeah, got it. That makes sense.
>> Gotcha. All right. Cool. This is going
to be a very cool environment once it
like it works correctly. Any of these
like swarming things, they end up
looking very very cool. So,
>> Right. Yeah. Yeah. I'm really excited.
>> Get the stuff down,
>> right? Yeah.
>> It'll get quicker. Like you will you'll
basically after a while once you've
built a few Ms you'll stop making like
mistakes like that and you'll be able to
debug stuff way more quickly.
>> Yeah. Cool. I'm looking forward to it.
>> All right. Thanks, man.
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you, Joseph. I really appreciate
your time. Have a good one, man.
>> Bye.
That was fun.
So yeah, for the uh the folks on YouTube
and Twitch here, if you come build cool
environments,
uh I will help look through the code
with you
provided that they are open source
projects that are eventually going to
get into Puffer Lib so that we can use
them for research.
You know, it's kind of counterintuitive
sometimes which of the tasks end up
being super useful for research.
Okay, we'll get a new policy for our
drones for
will merge my PR.
I don't have time to look at it, Mad
Jitter. I have like I got to go in five
minutes for meeting. I will look at it
though. How to analyze problems for RL?
That's too broad of a question. My best
general advice is going to be in that
article that I uh I wrote.
My best specific advice I'm going to
have to look at your your exact problem
or you can watch like you can watch how
I approach other users problems like I
just did with the amps one for instance.
It's kind of funny that it still works,
but yeah,
if you randomize, if you train
randomized, the original unrandomized
end will still work,
which is very nice. So, what this is
here, this is like I've trained the same
drone racing task, but now every single
time it finishes the course, it's going
to change to a different
Whoops. It's going to change to a
different size drone with different
weight, different inertia, and
everything randomized. So, you can kind
of think of it as this is training with
like
how many do we think?
>> Probably like a few hundred thousand
different drones.
like different types of drones.
And the idea is that this makes this
makes it a lot more stable when we go to
evaluate on the real drone because it's
going to be able to fly like any type of
drone. So, if the training setting
doesn't quite match the evaluation
setting, it doesn't matter because the
policy is super robust and it's been
trained to control basically whatever
drone we want.
Yeah. So right here, look, this is a
super big drone right here. This one's
big and it's slow, but you can see it's
still like able to reasonably maneuver.
And it knows that even though this drone
handles completely differently from the
other ones, it's like still able to do
something at least. Now, the thing is
not all the drones are reasonable. So
like it can get through the ring there,
but not all of them handle super well.
Like this one's really sluggish and hard
to maneuver.
So, it's just having a tough time, but
still it's able to do something, which
is cool.
And then this comes down to the exact
randomizations that we run, right? Like
we should make sure that all the drains
drones that we train on at least handle
well enough that you can do the task
where this one it's like maybe you can
barely do the task. Sort of. It's pretty
awkward. H. No, it's doing it like it's
just we're allowing it to pass back
through the same ring after it touches
it. So, it's doing it in a way that
looks kind of weird, but it is doing it.
Keeps getting bigger and bigger. Yeah,
this one's like this one's just
ridiculous at this point, right?
No, we had a smaller one at the start,
right? Let's just see one more. Oh,
yeah. There it is. So, this is the small
drone, right? Super zippy, way easier to
control. Yeah, this one works way
better.
Cool. Okay. Well, I've got to go for a
meeting. Um, thank you folks for tuning
in. I am traveling tomorrow and then I
will work on getting my stream set up in
California. I may have to buy some extra
stuff, but I will try to get it set up
ASAP. And uh, yeah, there will be much
more dev streamed from there. If you're
interested in my work more generally,
everything is available at puffer.ai.
This is all open source. You can get
involved with dev today just by joining
the Discord. If you want to help me out
for free, just star the buffer. Just
star the repo. It really, really helps
when people start the repo. Um, it just
does a lot for us. And if you want more
content, you can follow me on X where I
post lots of RL, including a bunch of
great articles uh for learning that you
can't find anywhere else. So, thank you
folks. We'll be back
probably Wednesday, maybe tomorrow
evening. will say.